durant quelques jours le couvent des
cordeliers qui accueille les expositions
mises en place par les musées de la
ville s'est transformée en maison de
noël passées la lourde porte la magie
s'installe c'est la machine noël et là
on est vraiment dans une thèmes
lumineuse sais je peux dire des décors
de noël il y en a pour tous les goûts et
pour tous les âges
on est émerveillé de voir les petits
émerveillé je crois que c'est surtout ça
voilà c'est absolument magnifique
voilà le cadre déjà le couvent des
cordeliers se prête au gigantisme de
l'exposition l'art il du haut de ses 9
ans à son sapin préférés et les lois
d'être le seul
j'aime les rênes et il se trouve que
sapin est beau
les booms sont magnifiques à toi comment
tu des corps chez toi tu mets quelques
couleurs en général pour le sapin guide
rouge
[Musique]
doré du argenté l'artisan de cette
maison de noël c'est lui fabrice fair un
fleuriste de son état il fut champion de
france mais aussi décorateur dans l'âme
ce qui lui vaut d'être sollicités pour
les plus grands événements comme pour
les plus privées alors vous pouvez lui
demander comment décorer son sapin de
cette année le rouge
intemporel lui toujours fidèle au poste
où tous les ans la grande tendance et on
est sûr de l'exotique un peu dans les
couleurs un peu vert vert sapin or et
bronze
la maison de noël fermera ses portes le
24 novembre au soir mais on pourra
retrouver le savoir-faire de fabrice
ferrain et son équipe
ce sont eux qui décoreront le
traditionnel sapin de noël installé sur
la place de la république